we've got to keep moving come on there's
a quick jump from the other side of the
space there are plenty of familiar
things in Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens its gameplay puzzles and basic
structure are all well-worn and even
some of that trademark goofy Lego humor
is starting to feel a little predictable
but that doesn't mean it's not fun this
game is in a mold breaker in the same
way the superior Lego dimensions was but
it is an engaging fun and charming title
that's well suited for families it's
also goofy enough for adult fans of Star
Wars to get a few giggles out of
the game follows the plot of the movie
closely with levels taking place on the
desert planet of jakku the forest of
takodana
on Starkiller base and many more you can
play as dozens of different characters
from this movie and other Star Wars
films but for the bulk of your first
run-through the game story mode you'll
be in charge of key characters from The
Force awakens such as Ray Finn Han Solo
Chewbacca Poe Dameron and bb-8 this is a
game aimed at young children so
character controls are simple and we
limited lives at immediate respawns
there's no real penalty for death as is
standard with the Lego games many
characters have unique abilities which
are used to solve puzzles or access
specific areas none of it is too
challenging but the fun is in the way
you'll have to swap between multiple
characters to achieve objectives logo
games are built for co-op enjoyment and
the force awakens is no different the
puzzles are just hard enough that
younger players will require adult
assistance to solve making it an ideal
game for some outstanding kid and grown
up gang sessions there's also a new
mechanic added to puzzle solving the
ability to choose which Lego structures
to build to solve some puzzles but it
adds little to the overall experience
combat is the weaker half of Lego Star
Wars most enemies in the game can be
defeated through simple button mashing
save for a few bosses that requires some
Loosli time quick time events to
vanquish there is one new addition to
battles here in some levels characters
can duck behind cover and shoot at
enemies but the game's concessions to a
younger audience make this addition
challenge free hitting the left trigger
automatically targets an enemy so
there's never any need to actually aim
the Lego formula may be well traveled by
now but it's still a pleasant one to
experience even though a lot of your
enjoyment will depend on your affinity
with the Star Wars universe simple
though they might be I still found alive
in many of Lego Star Wars levels it was
exciting flying poe dameron's x-wing for
example dogfighting against waves of TIE
fighters emits chatter from my fellow
pilots
you want to keep for yourself
and while the goofiness in mr. Lego
games approach their source material has
now become somewhat rote it's still
elicited a few laughs from me
there are even several extra levels that
expanding the events from the film for
Star Wars fans these are exciting
additions and it's given more
authenticity by the inclusion of nearly
the entire cast of The Force awakens who
recorded new lines of dialogue for the
game it's wonderful if your style was
completionist but it's also annoying as
these new non-film levels are hard to
access they're locked away until you
earned the requisite number of gold
bricks within the game so you're going
to need to play a lot of lego star wars
to experience them all but playing a lot
of Lego Star Wars The Force awakens
won't be a chore especially if you do
have a younger partner to take with you
in your galactic journey lego star wars
the force awakens doesn't really take
you to a new galaxy far far away but
it's still a pleasant journey han Solo